what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and one of the projects
that fans are really excited for myself
included is the upcoming Thunderbolts
project it had been reported that a
Thunderbolts project was in the works at
Marvel Studios for some time now and
then this year at San Diego Comic-Con
Marvel Studios revealed the entirety of
their Phase 5 slate with the last
project being the Thunderbolts coming
out July 26th of 2024 and not only did
they reveal the movie to us but they
revealed the roster of the Thunderbolts
as well and the roster is awesome we
have Elena Bulova we have the Winter
Soldier AKA Bucky we have us agent John
Walker we have ghost from Ant-Man and
the WASP we have Taskmaster from Black
Widow who fans are kind of on the fence
about right now we have the Red Guardian
and then we have Valentina Allegre de
Fontaine it's an awesome roster with
more people said to be coming in the
film not necessarily A Part part of the
Thunderbolts team but in the film
nonetheless right now fans have been
wondering why isn't Zemo a part of this
team but recent rumors suggest that he
is going to be in the film just not an
official member of the Thunderbolts team
but there is a big question that fans
have been asking recently and that
question is is Thunderbolt Ross going to
be in the Thunderbolts film in the
comics the Thunderbolts team is named
after Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross however
recently and very sadly the actor that
played Thunderbolt Ross in the MCU
William Hurt passed away and since
Marvel Studios decided to not recast
t'challa in Black Panther 2 fans were
wondering if they were going to do the
same for Thunderbolt Ross however it is
now officially confirmed that Harrison
Ford will be playing Thunderbolt Ross in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe making his
debut in Captain America 4 New World
Order and then of course we expect him
to show up in the Thunderbolts film and
we expect the team to be named after him
as well and today we have some supposed
plot points for the Thunderbolts movie
now before we get into this this is not
confirmed and it's just something that
somebody posted anonymously online so
take it with a big grain of salt but a
lot of these have actually been true
recently and it's fun to dive into them
so let's see what it has to say about
the plot for the Thunderbolts now what's
really interesting is it starts off by
saying that Scarlett Johansson is an
executive producer of the movie now this
is interesting because not too long ago
it was reported that Scarlett Johansson
was in talks to direct a Marvel film but
considering the fact that three members
of the Thunderbolts team are going to be
from Black Widow Red Guardian Taskmaster
and Yelena bilova and considering the
fact that the Thunderbolts movie is
probably going to talk about how
Valentina told Yelena that Hawkeye
killed Natasha there's definitely going
to be a lot of talk about Black Widow in
this movie so it would kind of make
sense that Scarlett Johansson would be
an executive producer of the film and
who knows maybe we'll go on to find out
that they'll announce her as the
Director of the film not just the
executive producer but we'll have to
wait wait and see on that it continues
to say Zemo appears in the movie but he
is not a member of the team he is more
like an advisor to Val similar to
Coulson was to Fury now depending on how
they do this this could actually work
very well because I would really love
for Zemo to form the masters of evil and
him not being a full member of the
Thunderbolts team means that he can
later go on to do this it continues to
say Molina also appears as chief of
operations of the team now they're
talking about Molina vostokov another
person from Black Widow and considering
how she helped drakoff run the red room
and is definitely in some sort of
trouble with the American government and
most likely the world it makes sense
that Val would want her for a part of
this team now here's where it gets
interesting it says that Songbird is
part of the team she wasn't announced at
d23 because there is no cast yet
although Ella Purnell is the front
runner for being Melissa Gold now
Songbird is a really cool character in
Marvel Comics she has really really cool
Powers with her her voice she can create
Sonic blasts you can even create force
fields with her voice and she can even
create some objects with her voice as
well she can create platforms she can
create battering rams basically her
voice is a crazy cool weapon she also
has the same abilities that a typical
superhero would have like superhuman
strength superhuman speed she can also
use her voice to create wings of pure
energy so she's pretty cool and I hope
this ends up being true and Della
Purnell could definitely lock down this
look now here's where it gets kind of
crazy it's revealed that Val is the
director of damage control which in all
honesty if this is true doesn't surprise
me that much damage control is
definitely kind of iffy when it comes to
a lot of things like them attacking kids
so it would make sense that Val would be
behind it because let's face it she's
kind of sketchy it says that there are
going to be teases for World War Hulk in
this film and since Captain America 4 is
going to be the movie coming out right
before the Thunderbolts film and it's
been rumored to have other hulks in it
that would make sense that they would
continue to tease a World War Hulk in
this film now of course many people are
going to be wondering after Hawkeye
after Yelena Bulova now knows that
Valentina lied to her about who killed
her sister she's obviously going to have
some beef with Valentina and one of the
plot points that this mentions is that
Yelena has her own agenda against Val
for lying to her about Natasha's death
and she tries to convince the others a
part of the team to remove Valentina
from the team and from here we kind of
get a mini Civil War storyline it seems
Alexi Bucky and Taskmaster are with
Elena for using Nat's death and ghost us
agent and Songbird are with Val because
Val gave them a new reason to be
important to be needed so as you can
imagine there is a fight between the two
different groups the separation so
there's gonna be a fight and I gotta say
I'm here for it because I'd love to see
a fight between us agent and the Red
Guardian both of them have taken super
soldier serum or at least some type of
it a variant of it if you will but
essentially both are super soldiers who
have fought with shields before so I
think this will be a pretty cool fight
now from here here it gets kind of
questionable and I'll explain what I
mean by that in just a second it says
because of yelena's treason Val murders
Molina and of course Molina is like her
mom or the closest thing that she's ever
had to a mom and apparently this leads
to yulina killing Val and the team is
disbanded after this now this part is
entirely believable it is definitely
something that Valentina would do and
Yelena would definitely kill Val after
all she almost killed Hawkeye and
Hawkeye is a good guy I'm sure she would
gladly kill Valentina after Valentina
killed her mom or like I said the
closest thing to it now I don't really
see Molina having a huge part in the MCU
moving forward after a Thunderbolts
movie so her dying in the film isn't
really that big of a shock I can buy
that however Julia louis-dreyfus's
character Valentina she was seemingly
set up to have a pretty big part in the
MCU now that could all be leading to
this movie The Thunderbolts in which
that could be the end for her which I
totally buy but at the same time I feel
like Marvel Studios might want to keep
her around for a little bit longer now
this does finish by saying that the team
is disbanded until the post-credits
scene where U.S agent ghost and Songbird
receive a message from a user named
citizen V citizen V is a Superhero in
Marvel Comics and many people have
actually been citizen V taken on the
mantle and at one point in time even
Zemo had taken on the mantle but he did
it as a villain pretending to be good he
even put a group of villains together
pretending to be superheroes until they
were eventually discovered and defeated
by The Avengers but it would make sense
that if Zemo is sort of on the sidelines
kind of helping out just a little bit
that at the end of this film if Val is
gone he would pop up and try to create a
team of his own because we definitely
know that he's not good he is a villain
now I like this I think this is all good
and well however I'm not sure Marvel
Studios has planned this far out yet
we're about two years away so I really
doubt that the post-credits scene for
this film has been written yet however I
do think that there is some validity to
other things that have been said on here
and actually some of this is just common
knowledge of what would actually happen
in this film it's very obvious that
Elena is not just going to be okay with
Valentina lying to her so she's clearly
going to go up against Valentina and of
course Red Guardian is going to take her
aside I would assume that Bucky would
take her side as well because of Natasha
and his relationship with her and of
course Steve Rogers but you as agent
John Walker has been recruited by
Valentina so it would make sense that he
would take her side and some other
members take her side as well and
considering they're kind of a group of
villains them fighting each other is
definitely going to happen and honestly
I see Valentina being the head of damage
control now the movie may not be fully
scripted out yet but Marvel Studios
definitely has a plan leading up to the
film and they have an idea of what they
want to happen in the film as well so
all of this is completely believable
except for the ending for the
post-credits scene and I kind of expect
it to happen and what some insiders do
sometimes is they put in the truth mixed
with some of their own theories which
I'm kind of assuming is happening here
but hey let me know what you think about
all this in the comments down below I'd
actually like to see a lot of this play
out on screen but let me know what you
think don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news for live updates
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf